Dan thanks for being here there's some
breaking news today on a couple of
fronts one is that the White House has
said that the Israelis have agree to
these 4-Hour pauses in the war what will
that get them the theory is it will get
them some hostages back the the numbers
are talking about 12 to 15 hostages it
sounds like a majority of them are
American hostages or H hostages that
have dual asrael American
citizenship the risk of course for the
Israelis is any one of these pauses in
mil milary fighting are being requested
for by Hamas because they're effective
and any moment Israel takes its you kind
of foot off the pedal means that Hamas
can reorganize they're in these tunnels
they're trying to get supplies into
these tunnels they're trying to
reorganize their fighting strategy
they're trying to reorganize their
defensive strategy they're under a lot
of stress the Israeli War fighting
strategy is working it is effective now
all the obvious caveats these things are
effective until they're not but so far
succeeding the idfx expectations and for
those reasons Hamas wants a pause so
they're willing to offer a few hostages
to get a pause and why is a White House
announcing that I think the White House
wants to send a message to everyone in
the International Community who they're
under pressure from but more importantly
from their Left Flank In the Democratic
Party from from whom they're under a lot
of pressure and I think showing that you
know President Biden has been very
public that he's locking arms with
Israel we we've talked about he flew to
Israel he attended a war his War cabinet
he's spoken in very emotional emotive
terms uh about what happened in Israel
on October 7th and I think this is one
of a handful of ways he's trying to send
a message to the left in his own party
who are very hostile to his position on
Israel hey I'm trying to I'm trying to
dial things down I'm trying to I'm
trying to bring the temperature down
that follows President Obama last
weekend suggesting that
Biden maybe he didn't say his name
specifically but basically he might as
well he should have right and and it
sounded like that's what he was meaning
and it kind of put President Biden on an
island on his own yeah I actually I I
was struck in a very negative way by the
comments President Obama uh made for a
variety of reasons one the the public
pressure was putting on the on the Biden
White House which is just not helpful
have these conversations behind the
scenes there's plenty of other people in
the Democratic Party there plenty of
critics internationally that are beating
up the Biden administration's approach
to Israel he doesn't need to hear it
publicly from his predecessor a B I
think the substance of what President
Obama said was was shockingly
ill-informed now he's not a dumb man so
I can't believe he's actually
ill-informed which makes me wonder if he
was making those comments in good faith
he basically referred to the occupation
as though yes the the atrocities were
terrible but you need to understand the
perspective of life for the Palestinians
under occupation except these
Palestinians aren't under occupation
these Palestinians are living in a strip
of land a small piece of land that
Israel withdrew from 18 years ago Israel
has not been there Hamas has been there
Hamas staged a violent coup against
another Palestinian government governing
Authority in 2007 to take over this
territory Israel has not been under has
not been occupying the Gaza Strip so I'm
not sure what President Obama was
talking about and
secondly I look there was a ceasefire on
October 6th right it ended on October
7th there was a ceasefire between Hamas
and Israel so if you just take a step
back and say you know he keeps saying
it's complex you need to understand all
these story lines okay so let's let's
let's let's address that complexity
Israel has been out of the Gaza Strip
since 2005 in on October 7th of 2023
Hamas wages a
genocidal
Invasion on Sovereign Israeli territory
that is not in dispute no one is
suggesting for a moment that there's a
future deal to be done where any of the
territory that was invaded by Hamas
would wind up in a Palestinian State
even the most far-left peace process
Advocates two State solution Advocates
anywhere in the world in Israel in the
Arab world none of them in the
Palestinian leadership none of them are
suggesting that the areas that were
attacked in Sovereign Israel are in
dispute so they launched into this
territory that was not dispute uh not
under
dispute and
they I mean I'm asked all the time what
was the point of what the what Hamas did
on October 7th the violence and the
barbarism was the point that was the
point and you know it was the point
because that's what they chose to
broadcast around the world they didn't
try to hide it that was the message so
that's quite simple what happened you
don't need complexity you don't need
Nuance we saw what happened on October
7th so now you look at it from the
Israeli decision maker standpoint they
have to respond they have to take out
this barbaric genocidal entity that sits
on their southern border when I say sits
on their southern border I don't mean
it's you know thousands of miles away or
it's in a battlefield in the other it's
a you can see it yeah it's it's a 2hour
drive from Tel Aviv the center of the
country the biggest population
concentration civilian population Center
in the country is a two-hour drive from
that and if you're you're right if
you're in steroid you're in southern
Israel you're you're literally right
there you're like looking right at it so
is has to take out Hamas so Israel does
not choose for Hamas where Hamas locates
its Battlefield its terrorism
headquarters right the Hamas chooses
that under hospitals they cooll
collocate it with schools so Israel can
do everything it's it can to encourage
civilians to get out of Dodge to head to
Southern Gaza to get out of these areas
but at some point it has to take out
these these terrorists and it has to
take out their military capabilities or
it's going to have another October 7th
and another one after that it has to do
that it can encourage people to get out
it can provide all the information it it
can sometimes at the expense of its own
military Effectiveness by the way
because it's broadcasting where it's
going to be going and um and it can try
to do a lot from the air before it sends
in the ground troops but at some point
it has to go in and so my question for
President Obama is who who's actually
responsible for Palestinian civilian
casualties it's Hamas Hamas Hamas is IES
to maximize Israeli civilian casualties
and actually to use Palestinian civilian
casualties as a war fighting strategy
from on the pr front and so again
President Obama is not a dumb man so the
fact that he could say something that is
so ill informed is and and I don't
believe he's ill-informed I I actually
think it was intentional yeah and you
know there's the theory uh that there's
only one president at a time even
president Trump has laid off of
President Biden in this and give Biden
the space he needs to do that so let's
though talk about your book um just just
set the stage though just so people can
understand how do you know so much about
Israel it's a great question I haven't
been asked that uh I'm glad you asked me
that uh I was uh I was born in a very
Zionist home so I was born in Upstate
New York uh lived in Canada for a number
of years uh my mother's a holocaust
Survivor she was a she was hidden as a
child by what we call Righteous Gentiles
uh uh which are non Jews in Eastern
Europe in Germany during World War II
who HIIT out Jews who risked a great
with great risk to their own lives did
it in fact the person who hid my mother
out and her mother
out had a close encounter because he was
hiding out Jews it's an extraordinary
story um these right where were they in
kosit which is a small town in
Slovakia uh and uh it's a few hours from
Bros laava and um she you hear this term
Jews in the Jewish Community you hear
the term righteous Gentile all the time
time because those are the people who
who risk their
lives I haven't heard the term in a long
time I mean if you study Holocaust
history you hear the term all the time
and in the last five or six
weeks more and more Jews given the
blowback this a little bit of a
digression given the blowback on the the
anti-Semitism blowback against Jews that
we've seen more and more Jews are saying
to themselves asking about people they
know friends War colleagues people who
run their kidso schools people who run
their kids colleges would they have
hidden me out if I if we were back in
the show if we were back in the
Holocaust would they have hidden me out
like there's St a question like because
there's stting there's this this sense
of like all these people turning their
backs uh on the Jews so anyways I grew
up I'm now I'm not giving you all my
baggage D interested it's interesting
this is what I was raised with that it
was it was a heavy upbringing uh meaning
I was raised my my my mother's father my
grandfather was killed at alitz my
mother and her mother escaped
before the train totz and that's how
they got on the run but how old was she
she was a little girl six you know five
seven years old my grandfather was
killed at alwoods Campbell and I were
there with my mother and our entire
family this summer we went back to her
hometown we went back to her home where
the Nazis took them out of um in kosit
we brought our whole family family from
Israel there was like 15 of us who
traveled it was it was quite moving
experience um so that's what I grew up
with on her side my father who who had
worked in he was an academic he had
worked a little bit in politics he
worked for the mayor of UA New York
where I was born until he lost his
election and he was also very involved
with Zionist activism in the US he
worked for a guy named Rabbi he was a
like a a protege of this guy named Rabbi
abah Hillel Sil who was a prominent uh
Zionist activist in Cleveland Ohio where
my dad was from who was a big Champion
for the founding of the state of Israel
he's one of these leading Jewish figures
who was trying to pressure The Truman
Administration to recognize uh Israel
and so my father had worked under him
and then my father had worked on a
number of Jewish and pro Israel causes
so this was like as I said it was like
in the water in my home uh I have uh
because it was in the water so to speak
I have two sisters who ultimately made
the decision to move to Israel and make
their lives there largely because of his
influence uh and uh and my mothers and
they um have raised children there each
of them have three
kids my my one of my sisters has a
daughter who been called up to reserves
her husband Saul singer is the co-author
of our book and we were co-authors of
startup Nation to uh he uh so they have
a daughter who's been called up my other
sister has three sons two of the three
sons have been called up plus a grandson
and plus a niece so it just gives you a
sense of how everyone so you're in it in
it in it and um so when I do my
reporting and ant analysis on your show
and others I'm bringing to it my sort of
my analytical lens but you know I also
have I'm talking to real people who are
like living this um and so I spent this
was I was sort of raised with this um I
I studied for a year in Israel uh at the
Hebrew University of Jerusalem when I
was in college I I did some work there I
did some research as an intern for the
Chicago tribunes Middle East Bureau and
then I got interested in Israeli
startups I started investing in Israeli
entrepreneurs and so between all those
things family business personal interest
upbringing me I'm in Israel about every
two or 3 months and um I you know I feel
very deeply deeply connected to quickly
how do you describe it what what does it
mean to be a Zionist activist yeah
uh I may I mean I guess it's to say
you're a Zionist means you believe in
the the the idea that the Jews deserve
and need to build a state which
basically and is activist may be
redundant but it just means that I'm
involved in it I'm I'm I'm I've been a
I've been a voice for you know defense
of the Jewish State advocacy for the
Jewish State not in a formal way but
just an informal way I ask only because
I feel like there's a lot of terms that
are got up and that people are now like
wait what does it mean from the river to
the Sea and now everyone's getting a
real education and you're you have a
podcast called call me back I listened
to it before the War I love it I
recommended it to everybody but now it's
become this this in I have an insatiable
need for more information and and I can
find it there and I knew for a while
that you had this book coming out the
genius of Israel and I was looking
forward to reading it it's getting
amazing reviews I just read Brett
Stevens and commentary magazine terrific
you did an interview on commentary
magazine p podcast that I listen to um
and I want to ask you all about the book
but before I do because
things the book and its Outreach and
what it means I think really it didn't
change the content of the book but
October 7th changes this book yeah and
the approach of of promoting it because
I just wonder what you were thinking on
October 7th how did you find out that
October 7th was going down where were
you what was it like on October 6th uh
after we do a Friday night dinner uh
Shabbat dinner uh and um which we write
about I mean in our book we have a
chapter called Thanksgiving every week
which we talk about how Israelis um
celebrate Shabbat every week and how
it's a big part of not just the
religious religion but also the Civil
religion of Israeli life and it's a very
important
sort of element of the Israel's social
glue that keeps the country together
which which we can talk about and we we
we try to do that in our home here and
and we're very involved with the Jewish
Community uh here in New York uh many of
whom do something similar uh I you're
not supposed to be on electronic devices
on Shabbat depending on your level of
observance which I in in full disclosure
uh violate uh you're my friend you're
not my Rabbi so I can well on that on
that morning on October 7th I'm very
good friends as you with Ben Shapiro and
I kept thinking how is Ben going to find
out that this is happening and I later
learned the story of how he did but so
um and that was that was an especially
important day because that was uh it was
a Jewish holiday Sim Torah so a lot of
religious Jews who normally would be in
services in synagogue for Shabbat but
it's also this added layer of a very
important holiday um I before I went to
bed late that night I just glanced at my
phone uh just before I crashed which was
late on Friday night and um and I saw in
all my WhatsApp groups with Israelis I
have a lot of Israeli
friends I started seeing chatter on
these WhatsApp groups where they're like
cuz it was 7 hours ahead and they're
like something's going on you know still
early morning in Israel at that point
right they're like something's going
on and but I I discounted it at the time
because I thought uh you know it's just
the usual Israel Gaza Skirmish and it
all you know I just didn't think it was
any different than May of 21 or 2000
Summer of of uh 22 or I mean these
things pop up and they pop down I
thought it was a version of that other
in retrospect the way they were talking
there was a sense that it was worse than
that because um there was something
about a land it wasn't just Rockets
being fired there was something about a
land a border penetration which has
never happened so I was like a little
curious but figured it was probably more
of what we've seen some some sort of
pattern recognition and I went to bed
and then got up the next morning and I
checked again and by then all my Israeli
friends were like they were just talking
about tens you know close you know 40 50
60 there was 100 people dead now in
Israel a population of you know 9.3
million people 100 people dying in a
single attack let alone 1,400 plus but
at that point we didn't know those
numbers but you know 100 people it's a
lot of people uh and uh as a as a
proportion of the population so I knew
at that point it was probably real and
this was different and then the other
way I knew it was really different is
and I haven't talked about this publicly
my sister who is uh eight years older
than me lives in Jerusalem uh lives
around the corner for my mother she is
um she's very she's a very observant Jew
very religious I mean not Orthodox but
you know somewhere close to it and uh
she is completely shuts off of
electronic devices on Shabbat from
Sundown on Friday nights till Sundown on
Saturday night she's completely
unreachable I mean really unreachable I
mean obviously if there were an family
emergency she would but otherwise and I
was thinking about this in my
entire as far as I can remember my
relationship with her okay um I don't
remember ever having a conversation with
her on Shabbat or Jewish holiday another
Jewish holiday like never I cannot think
of of another time ever she just she's
very literally figuratively religious
about it and I called her phone which I
would never do I called her cell phone
and she answered and I knew when she
answered the phone this was serious uh
because I just knew I said this will be
a test because if something's really
going if it's really bad she will answer
the phone and she answered and she told
me and we talked a lot about it it was
clearly at that point very serious she
gave me two images she left with me two
images that I've I've thought a lot
about uh one was shoes at synagogue that
day and in the middle of the services
the sirens were going off and she
everyone had to get out of there and
they she's was at this little Orthodox
synagogue in Jerusalem and they were
like debating well what do we do we're
in the middle of the service like do we
just stop the service and and then
everyone agreed they needed to stop the
service and on that holiday is um what's
called the yker service which is a a
service for um During certain Jewish
holidays where you where you go it's
like a almost like a collective memorial
service for for anyone who's lost a
loved one and so she they said okay
we'll wait for the end of the Yar
service and then we'll all scatter
otherwise we'll cut the service short so
they finish the Yar service and then
someone said well before we all scatter
Sirens are going off they're in this
little synagogue Sirens like Nationwide
are going off and they say okay well
before we all
scatter let's do a prayer for the state
of Israel for this for the you know the
health and vitality so they do the
prayer it's called for The Med Israel
it's a it's a it's a prayer in In the
Jewish liturgy and then um they said
okay let's go wait wait before we go
let's just do a prayer for the Israeli
soldiers because they're about to go
through hell and so they did that prayer
and my sister said they finished that
prayer and then they were it was like
everyone scattered and she said when she
was she ran home cuz she had to get cuzz
all these homes have bomb shelters in
Israel they had to get to these like
bomb shelters and she was running home
and she said the last image she she saw
before she got home running home in
Jerusalem on Shabbat it's it's you can't
hear a pin drop I mean the city really
shuts down and she saw cars whizzing by
which you never see on Shabbat in Israel
and she saw cars driving by and the
people driving the cars had yamakas on
so they were religious Jews now again
the image of a religious Jew driving a
car on Shabbat you never see anywhere
she knew they were rushing to reserve
duty they were rushing to hospitals and
that all had when you go back in history
that all had the feel of the 1973 yum
kipur War when Israel was under siege so
you I gave you a long answer I actually
haven't said that you it's fascinating
to hear
it one of the things you've said is that
Jews Fe feel that they can touch history
and shape it m and one of the things I
was wondering about like even with your
sister is that because you're you you go
back and you visit your mom's
Hometown but that was you know that was
the never again right and so your
generation you and your sister and even
your children are thinking well we have
to keep that memory alive we have to
understand the history but we're never
going to have to do that again right
because never again right but now here
we are yeah I this this that
look as as a as an analyst of events in
the Middle East in
Israel s of consider myself sort of a
participant and sort of an analyst um
but as an analyst I've always been able
to keep a little bit of distance because
I know people In Harm's Way in Israel
whenever there's a conflict or whenever
there's a security
threat but I I'll be honest like I don't
feel vulnerable I don't actually feel
vulnerable in these situations I heard
all these stories from my mother growing
up and my mother was always like very
suspicious and very like you know not in
a bad way she came by it honestly like
she gone through this incredible trauma
and and even what she did after the war
when she was on the run I mean it's it's
it's an unbelievable story and uh I
never
felt I've I've I've led a successful
life I mean in the west in the United
States professionally like we have all
this you know Jews have all these rights
and you know influence like what what
could you
know this is the first time I have felt
vulnerable and it pops up in weird ways
uh but I I just my kids go to a Jewish
Day School I you know you see the NYPD
cars now since October 7th sitting in
front of the school every morning um you
I just it's all the conversations with
the kids it's you know silly things like
you know you have a dog I have dogs I
walk to dogs late at night and it's
pitch black and like I'm not I don't
have no profile I'm not like some but
I'm out there on this stuff and like you
know and so I'm walking around the
neighborhood with the dogs late at night
you just start to you start to wonder
and this is the first time in your life
you felt that way I've ever felt that
way and there's something even after 911
I didn't I felt 911 I felt the country
was under siege right but that's
different than this is different because
after 911 it was like the country was
attacked and I knew the would respond
and the US would bolster defenses yeah
but this is different than like that
what I being targeted as a Jew like
there was a Jew hunting quality to it
now that and and again this didn't hit
me the first few days after it's it's
it's more in the last couple weeks the
sense that um it's weirdly being
tolerated I feel it for you it's like
normalized like
the the diner the coffee shop on the
upper side yeah who supports Israel and
then he has staff resign and door Dash
you can no longer order from there or I
guess door Dash is try to fix that and
then there's all these people that come
out like no we're going to frequent your
store like I want to be a customer and I
said Peter I want to go right I've had
20 coffees today I clearly don't need
any more but like I want to go and I I I
feel it one of the things you also talk
about is that what happens in Israel
matters yeah why does it matter here why
should people here care
yeah so um so I let me let me address
that and tie to your to your early
question about um so M Goodman is one of
these guys we interview in the book
who's a big public intellectual he's had
a lot of influence on my
thinking uh and he says that Israel is
in that chapter called touching history
he says Israel is a small country with a
big story and I love that line small
country in fact I wrote it down here
small country with a big story and what
he says and we describe the scene when
we go on a hike with him where he's
getting into all this with us and it's
very dramatic the part of Israel we're
looking at we're going hiking so I don't
think that was his intention but but the
whole thing became very moving but he
basically said look there are plenty of
small countries in the world right
Europe is full of small countries I grew
grew up effectively in Canada which was
is a smallish country I guess now
mediumsized country he goes they're all
wonderful countries more or less they
don't really have big stories like what
happens there doesn't really matter in
the scheme of things they try to improve
the quality the standard of living
quality of life it's all very important
but that's basically how those societies
are
judged you have you have big countries
with big Stories the United States is a
big country with a big story China love
it or hate it is a big country with a
big story but you don't have a lot of
countries in the world that are small
with big stories yeah I would think
maybe
Rwanda would be a small country with a
big story but not the same story because
your first book Is startup nation which
is about the amazing entrepreneurial
spirit that you have invested in and
that has helped you you become a
successful person as well but now you
have the genius of Israel and one of the
things I don't know if you came up with
it or or M did but you in there you talk
about a strong like in America we
have a strong government and a weak
Society right right but in Israel you
have a weak government and a strong
Society yeah and you talk about the
cohesiveness that
is critical for a healthy Society yeah
for in a healthy and thriving country so
you are I'm not going to you're not you
don't have dual citizenship I'm assuming
but pretty much you American you have
all these Israeli ties so you can see
this from both sides and I wonder what
is the lesson here for us in the United
States about how we could be a more
cohesive
Society with a strong government as well
so that we can do what is needed in the
world yeah so so if I could there are
like two or three things that I hope
Americans can take away from this book
and you're zering it on one of them
coming back to mik Goodman he tells
another story where in 2016 after Trump
was
elected he goes to a conference at
Harvard he's an academic you know so he
has all these academic friends and peers
of his who work at in other institutions
in the United States he's based in
Israel goes to a
conference and all these Harvard
academics are sitting there talking
about the Trump voter I I read a study
about the Trump voter I I I met a trump
let me tell you what this Trump voter
said and he's like are you talking about
your fellow citizens I mean I get you
disagree with them politically but
you're talking about them as though
there's some like lab experiment like
there's some other thing do you do you
actually interact with them deplorables
right do you actually have commun are
you part of the same Community he found
it so unrelatable because in Israel
obviously they have deep political
division and we talk a lot about that in
the book but it doesn't come at the
expense of of feeling like a sense of
community with your fellow citizens and
and no one in Israel more or less feels
like other citizens are the Other M so
so let me say so one of the most
important things that that is that glue
that you're zering in on is most
Israelis serve in some kind of national
service it's the it's the military
there's some civilian Alternatives but
it's it's mostly the military and it's
two or three years unless they go on for
officer training programs so they go
into one of the elite units but it's
basically 2 3 years at formative ages 18
19 20 21 around there
and all of the you know all all of these
people come out of the military more or
less develop some extraordinary skills
and we go through the data in the book
about how many learn how many people
come out of the military at those ages
with real command experience management
experience leadership experience which
is like gold it's phenomenal for
building companies and startups and okay
that's part of the value that's very
interesting yeah yeah we go through how
many at any given time how many people
in their 20s and 30s have actually
managed big things the numbers are are
staggering
but what it also does is it it's it's a
structure in the society that takes all
these people from all walks of life and
has them working together in the unit uh
so it's it's in the military unit so if
you see even these images that you and I
have both both been marveling at that
have been coming out of this current
conflict that are quite inspiring you
see in the hull of a tank you know five
or an armored uh vehicle you know five
or six Israeli soldiers and you look
around and the from all walks life
there's very religious ones there's
radically secular ones with tattoos and
ponytails women there's there's uh
there's there's people from you know
North Africa who made who moved to
Israel there's people from the United
States who mooved there's people you
know there's sons of cab drivers and
Sons of tech billionaires and they're
all in that Hull of the hull of a tank
and they and it and so when you serve in
the Army there you not only do your 23
years but then you have reserve duty
many of them have reserve duty into
their 40s so with the same people so
you're with these people for a couple
weeks a year in your 20s in your 30s and
you build strong relationsships so M
says to me I never could by the way half
these people I think are crazy
politically I totally disagree with them
I'm with them all the time we defend the
country together we're we so so so
that's very special and and and and and
to your question and then the third
thing that I think I hope people think
about we and you alluded to it before
what's going on today on college campus
is is like so disorienting for not only
the Outburst of anti-Semitism but just
the sense that it's not clear to me that
many of these Elite colleges are making
our kids smarter or more Curious or more
thoughtful and if you look at the
application process to get into these
Elite you so this is like the the North
Star for so many families in America
today if I can just get my kid into this
college or that college what's the
process for getting in into the one of
these Elite colleges the entire
admissions process which so many
families build their whole lives around
for them or their kids it's about
individual Excellence I need to do great
on the I need to get great grades I need
to get great SATs i i i me me me I need
to do this I need to do that there's
never a we in that there's never you're
never evaluated on how you are with a
group what kind of teammate are you are
are you how are you as a member of a
community in Israel at every formative
stage of a young person's life all the
emphasis is on how you are as part of a
team and Community it's not to say
individual Excellence doesn't matter it
matters look at the Tech Community some
of these entrepreneurs have become
fabulously wealthy all the power to them
but at every stage of their life and
this begins with youth movements and
scouting movements it it includes how
they teach kids in classrooms which is
on group based on group learning the
group has to do well it's not about
personalized learning and then the
military you can't get into the best
units in the military you may be a
perfect candidate for flying planes in
the Air Force what a lot of people want
to get into but if you can't work with a
team you won't get in so the incentive
structure for the whole society is it's
not a enough for me to just crush it on
my own I also have to be able to work
with other people and when that's the
incentive structure that's
rewarded it changes the whole way the
society exists and the way people live
in that
Society fascinating you are donating the
proceeds of this book to a group called
zaka zaka it's a organizations zaka is
one um which has done some amazing
relief work and has also um there
they're doing a lot of sadly there's a
lot of work to be done with these
burials uh and the um and the helping
the families deal with all of it um and
so there's a separate pocket for those
re resources for that then there's
United hsala which is I think the guy
who runs it Ellie bear has been on your
guys air uh it's it's this um volunteer
it's a network of about 7,000
volunteer paramedics on these
motorcycles and they are it's an amazing
system they were some of the PE first
people on the scene on October 7th
they've been doing extraordinary work um
the work and and sadly it's not over uh
the work
of burying people and mourning people in
a country of 9.3 million people when you
when you think about, 1400 people so far
still a large number we don't know the
precise number still a large number of
Israelis whose bodies uh either have not
been identified or no one's been able to
account for meaning there's no there's
no trace of them having been taken to
Gaza and there's been no through DNA uh
evidence of their body having been
found many people and families are going
to multiple have been going to multiple
funerals I mean it's like it's like it's
just it it really is um overwhelming to
um think about so and I I'm sure
there'll be other projects that I
support but uh and I and maybe I should
you know advertise them you know I'm
just curious
because uh it was an incredible effort
to write the book yeah and then the book
and the meaning of the book changes
after the attack to me it did and I
think it's wonderful that you wrote it
um I think it's a great tribute to your
heritage and um I don't I don't want to
hear that my friends feel vulnerable
yeah um but I understand that you do and
I think other people need to hear it too
so thanks for joining us on the Fox News
rundown podcast